the president arrives and a gun salute
is fired by the Kings troop Royal Horse
Artillery and there will be 41 guns to
celebrate the president's arrival and
then after that another 41 guns to mark
that yesterday a Sunday was the
anniversary of the Queen's coronation
when sweaters will now lead the
president as the first lady's brought by
the Duchess of Cornwall and on the steps
of West Terrace at Buckingham Palace
waiting for the president on behalf of
the United Kingdom will be Her Majesty
the Queen
later this afternoon the president and
first lady would go to Clarence House to
be given afternoon tea with the Prince
of Wales and the Duchess of Cornwall
and into the poem after they
and the queen will entertain the
president and first lady while outside
the helicopters leave the garden of
Buckingham Palace and a scene of
ceremonial splendor will form as the
guard of honor will take position and
the household cavalry will line the
steps we've just seen the president come
up and go into Buckingham Palace